So how do you know how many samples to send?
How many leads do you send?
Is there a specific number?
Is there a specific timeframe?
And honestly, the answer is probably going to piss you off a little bit because there
is no set number of leads, there is no set timeframe, okay?
Because it's different for every person.
So only thing I want to mention on this is there's no set anything, okay?
I've had customers where I have sent three leads over the course of two weeks and somehow
I sold the deal.
I've had customers where I sent five leads in one day and I sold the deal.
I've had customers where I've sent one lead in half a day and I've sold the deal.
Every customer is different because every customer is at a different stage.
Every lead that you send is different.
And so all I want to mention on this, because this is a question I get frequently, is how
many should I send?
I have a couple of rules of thumb, but more than anything, above and honestly, the rules
of thumb are great, but this takes precedence, is it's a feeling.
And you're going to know.
And the more that you do this, the more you're going to know.
They're going to start asking questions and there's going to be this moment in time where
the iron is hot and you need to strike.
And sometimes it's not convenient.
Sometimes you are going on vacation tomorrow and they're ready to talk and you need to
stay up late and you need to do that call tonight.
Or you need to get up at 3 a.m. and you need to do that call before you go on vacation.
And I know it's not convenient.
And I know you'd rather do it after the vacation or on your time, but when the iron is hot,
you got to strike.
You have to strike because that is your opportunity, okay?
And it is a feeling and we're going to get more into this, but I'm telling you that you
just have to feel it.
Their customer is going to be ready.
You're going to know it.
They're going to start asking questions.
They're going to say, hey, when do you want to talk?
Hey, how does this work?
They're going to just put off certain vibes that are going to let you know.
And that is going to be something you're going to learn.
It's something that you have to do rep, rep after rep after rep to learn.
But I do want to share my two rules of thumb.
Outside of that, my rule of thumb is I never try to send more than five leads.
So usually my rule is this.
I send between three to five leads or when they close a deal.
So if I send one lead and they close a deal, I'm getting on the phone.
I don't care if it's the first day and they go and close it right on spot.
If it's the first day I do a duck cleaning lead, they close it over the phone.
I am doing a deal the second they close the lead.
So the second a business owner close one of your leads, you're freaking doing the deal.
However, you do not need to wait for them to close a deal.
So that's something else that gets confused.
You're not just going to send leads and send leads and send leads for them to close the
deal.
That's not how this works.
The purpose isn't for them to make money so they can pay you.
The purpose is for them to see what these are like, for them to go and see the quality
and talk to the customers and see that you're legit.
So they don't even actually have to run the estimates themselves for you to go and close
the deal.
Sometimes I'll send three leads, they'll schedule them, but they're a bit scheduled out so they'll
schedule them for like Thursday, Friday, Monday, and I'm closing the deal on Wednesday.
But they've at least seen these are real customers.
These are people that need estimates.
They want estimates.
These are exclusive leads and that is enough.
So I just want to let you guys know the rule of thumb is I send three to five leads or
they close a deal.
quicker.
That's what I do.
And that's usually a telltale sign that these guys are ready to go.
And then I hop on the phone and then I get on and do the screencast and I hop on the
zoom call and close the deal.
But again, more than anything, I want you guys to know this is a feeling and it's going
to be different on everyone.
It's not going to be, I send three leads, I jump on the phone.
We have these rules of thumb.
We don't send more than five.
We want to send at least three, or if they close one, we have these rules of thumb.
But guys, I want you to trust your gut.
I want you to listen to what they're saying.
I want you to sense when they're ready to go, when the iron is hot, and I want you to
strike.